things seem to be heating up again
between
kylie jenner and travis scott i love it
the two who share a three-year-old
daughter stormy webster
recently packed on the pda while
celebrating the rapper's 29th birthday
in miami
now a source says kylie and travis are
quote
messing around and having fun together
adding they've always had a strong
connection
and chemistry and they're exploring
their relationship romantically again
the 23 year old beauty mogul and the
rapper have had an
on-again off-again romance since 2017.
and e.t source says quote they've been
co-parenting so well together and have
a lot of love for each other everyone
around them can see that
[Music]
for travis's b day the pair enjoyed a
night out at live
nightclub's live on sunday party at the
fountain blue
where the birthday boy dj'd and
performed
[Music]
according to another source kylie and
travis were visibly together
and definitely seem to be enjoying
themselves and
each other's company and speaking of
birthdays
back in february kylie and travis went
all out to celebrate stormy turning
three we're talking a table
fit for a queen and an enormous slide
modeled after stormy's face
and kylie she shared this video of the
birthday girl
showing off some royal etiquette
but back to kylie and travis in february
a source told et they still act like
they're an item
and when it comes to little stormy the
trio are relatively inseparable for the
most part
the source added that there's little to
no drama in their co-parenting
and neither of them are interested in
dating others at this time